Hello, this is Dr.
Raj. I'm part of
the Family Medicine
Department and I will
be talking about
anxiety disorders.
If you need to reach
me, my email address is
anu.raj at nyit.edu.
And I encourage
you to get in
touch with me
if you have any
questions about
this lecture, okay?
So at the end of the
session, I really wanna
make sure you understand
the difference
between generalized
anxiety disorder panic
disorder social
anxiety disorder and to
really understand the
epidemiology behind
them to understand
the types of treatment
plans we use and other
kinds of risk factors
okay so why do we talk
about anxiety disorders
it is one of the
most common mental
health conditions it
often goes unrecognized
and given that we are
sort of very new in
the post-pandemic phase
during the pandemic
approximately 40
percent of the world's
population according
to the world health
organization was dealing
with some kind of
anxiety disorder or
another which makes
sense because our
existence was being
questioned and at one
point we didn't even know
the treatment options
we had available
to ourselves. So
remember that when you're
seeing patients in
primary care settings
to ask about worrying and
uncontrollable
worrying. The United
States Preventive
Services
task force actually gave
out a recommendation
last year where they
said that adults
should be screened
for anxiety disorders
so we use the
generalized anxiety
disorder scale seven
questions called the GAT7
in our clinic in
the Rhineland clinic
and the health care
center in Central Islip
so we've already
adopted it it is a
recommendation so I
encourage you guys
whenever you're on your
rotations to ask those
kind of questions
from your patients.
So let's talk about
what's pathology right
it's normal for all of
us to worry a little
and in some situations
you have to worry
so for example if you
have a test tomorrow
I'm hoping that you're
worried enough that
it'll motivate you to
study you know get all
your notes together
whether it's a study
group or on your own
and practice some
questions so that you'll
feel more prepared.
Without that, you know,
complacency sets in.
Pathological is
when it's excessive,
when it really does
take up a lot of your
cognitive space in
your brain, right?
When it's too intense.
So when you're asking
your patients, you
can ask them like, how
intense is it? Like
on a scale of one to
10, when you're really
anxious or worried.
And if they say, well,
consistently eight
or nine, that's a lot.
Well, then how many
hours in a day does
that happen um so you
ask about like how
chronic how long does
this happen oh it's
been happening for
months some patients
will say i think i've
been like this since
middle school i don't
ever remember not
worrying about things
and like i over worry
i overthink um and
does it impair you so
does it stop you from
in any way living
life the way you would
want it to live in its
fullest form that's
that's the definition
of impairment okay
why am I bringing that
up as a definition
for impairment by
the way is because
somebody with
OCD may actually
think that they're
not impaired but if
they're washing their
hands five times
and each time
they're washing their
hand for a period
of 60 to 70 seconds
that's interfering
with something right
now think about how
anxiety manifests itself
so you think about the
autonomic responses
right think about the
fight flight and I'll
talk about the brain
structure in a second
and then the emotional
aspect of you know
there's an edginess
there's a sense of panic
there's a sense of
unease there you know
they're wiggling in
their chair they then you
know there's a sense
of fear and then the
trains a train of thought
is something that's
gonna happen something
catastrophic is
gonna happen And then
there's also all or none
kind of thinking, like
it needs to all be
in control. I have to
know all the questions
on the test at a time
to prepare for it.
Or I got nothing
in my head. So
it's all or none
type of thinking.
And the behavioral
is what happens?
What do you do with
that anxiety? So
you ask your patient,
what do you do?
They're either
avoiding or they're
finding a way to
keep themselves safe.
And usually
avoidance is the go
-to method of coping.
with anxiety.
Now, what makes a person
more likely
to be anxious?
It's always an interaction
of genetics and
environment. It's never
one or the other. So
what were they born
with? If they were born
with a strong family
history of, say, OCD or
social anxiety, then
they have to keep an
eye on that? And of
course, what kind of brain
chemistry they were
born with themselves?
What have they done
with their own brain?
They may have altered
their brain chemistry
with substances or some
long-term medications
that may have had
an impact on brain.
What is the type
of temperament
that they were born
with, right? What
is their tendency
to do in life?
And what kind of
childhood experiences have
they had? Adverse
childhood experiences is
something the American
Psychological and the
American Psychiatric
Associations talk a lot
about lately because
a lot of children now
that they have now that
we have child protective
services and structure
to provide the
children with the
protection to tell us what's
happening some of
these children are
consistently telling us
about like these traumatic
events that happen
and then that clearly
will build child's
personality a certain way
it will make the child
more susceptible to
certain things a
certain way And then, of
course, there's the
dysregulation of, you know,
GABA and dysregulation
of serotonin
and cortisol
levels, right?
And what does
the amygdala do?
Here's just some, so
I want you to have
this picture in
mind as I tell you
about the brain
chemistry. um you have
the limbic system
where from the
prefrontal cortex the
information goes in
um goes to the amygdala
and then from there
the hypothalamus tells
you know the brain oh
do we need to have a
fight or flight response
and then the prefrontal
cortex system
again comes out with
the higher order of like
decision making what
do we do right and then
so let's take an
input for example say
somebody is afraid of a
loud noise you encounter
the loud noise that's
a sensory input
right your ears heard
it and you got rattled
um and so it went to
the thalamus which
is sort of like the
relay station like the
radio of the brain
and from there the
amygdala gets activated
and the so the thalamus
is saying something
bad's happening we
got rattled and the
amygdala is saying well
is it similar to
something else maybe
we're afraid we were
afraid we amygdala's
primary purpose for us
as humans is to make
us survive right and
we've had this from our
primitive ancient
as soon as we landed
from the trees onto
ground and started walking
on our hind legs
days so it is one of
the most primitive
structures in our brain
and it has survived
as such because
in its functioning
it has made
us survive
through evolution.
So when the amygdala
is informed by the
thalamus, we just
heard a loud noise.
The amygdala says, well,
let me assess the threat.
But before that, we
still first need to
be afraid because we
first need to recoil
into our shell and
decide what, and then
we'll decide what to
do, right so if we're
under attack we need
to first recoil gather
ourselves then decide
do we attack do
we flee what do we do
the hypothalamus and
it's the hypothalamic
sorry hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal
axis the hpa axis is
the one that gets
activated where it says
we're gonna release
cortisol because
we're getting ready
for a fight or a
flight you know is
there a bear out there?
If there is, we're
going to get ready
for either we're
going to fight the
bear or we're going
to run away from it.
And the prefrontal
cortex says, well,
we're helping you
make the decision.
And we do the higher
order thinking.
So we will determine
if the prefrontal
cortex says, it's really
not that much of a
threat. There's really
no bear out there.
It's just a
little rustling we
heard. And the loud
noise you heard
was like a squirrel
running around.
It's really not
that significant. So
the amygdala should
then calm down.
It should not be
blaring all sorts
of sirens, bells
and whistles, right?
In an anxious
brain, what happens
is the amygdala
cannot turn off.
So there's a lot of
anxiety and long-term,
ongoing, and even
the The smallest
sound will be
perceived as a threat
of, look, there's
a bear out there.
So similar to what I've
just said, this kind
of captures what happens
in our brain. And
again, this is happening
over microseconds.
when you're working with
patients with anxiety
disorders you yourself
need to know what
your own blind spots
are what your own
perceptions the way you
were reared and raised
and socialized are so
know what your thoughts
are about eating and
eating disorders know
what your thoughts are
about substances and
dependence know what
your thoughts are about
a patient who looks
a little different or
may come across a
little different i speak
with a slight accent
i'm sure you've detected
it um what your behavior
is towards somebody
who in some ways may
be a little different
than what you're accustomed
to also know what
your blind spots are
about mental illness
because if you are not
aware of some of your
blind spots your
brain as well will go
into something's different
something's rough
so you will also over
pathologize the reason
i want to bring this up
right away is because
i want to weave this
into every single
exposure you have
about mental health and
mental illness right
there's enough stigma
and discrimination
that happens for mental
health there's enough
stigma around mental
illness there's there's
enough of it if you
think about it approximately
if approximately
40 of the world
according to world health
organization three
years ago had anxiety do
you think 40 of the
world i went out and
sought help no um because
people are told well
it's all in your
head um and if any of
you are harry potter
fans um remember that
dumbledore told harry
potter of course it's
in your head but that
doesn't mean it's not
real right there are
brain structures we
haven't fully learned
about yet but we know
enough about them to
know that the cortisol
levels are high and
if the cortisol levels
are high your functioning
overall functioning
is going to drop because
you're busy dealing
with the stress so
the last thing as a
physician i would hope
you would do is say
oh you need to try
harder um you should know
what the person is
coming with there there
are some of all of
their life experiences.
So somebody with a
generalized anxiety
disorder, remember
the acronym WATCHERS.
Do they worry a lot?
Are they anxious?
Is there tension
in their muscles?
Does that interfere
with their capacity
to concentrate? So
when I was talking
about interference
and, you know, does it
interfere with life?
These are some ways
you can ask somebody
how it interferes
with life. Can you
concentrate on things?
Are you irritable a
lot? Have your friend
said or noticed you
know you're a bit
cranky lately um have
you noticed there's
a difference in your
energy level are
you finding you can't
sit still and you're
restless are you
getting the same quality
and quantity of
sleep as you used to
now for generalized
anxiety disorder
people who tend to
have lower scs are
unmarried or come from
underrepresented groups
tend to have
higher levels
of generalized anxiety.
Well, because if you
have a lower SES and
you can't have your
primary needs met,
you're going
to be anxious.
You may be
required to do more
to meet the basic
requirements
to be able to exist
for your family
members and
your dependents.
um it's higher for
female than it is
for male because
a women who are
menstruating tend
to also have some
of the emotional
regulation issues
with the different
levels of hormones
in addition to that
women are also reared
and raised in a society
to act a certain way
and behave a certain
way and when you cannot
be your fullest self
-actualized person it's
harder to interact
um so don't go around
telling your patients
it's your hormones okay
um this is a really
good picture of how the
limbic limbic system
actually functions so
you can do that in
your free time and also
combine it with your
neurology lectures i
also don't want to
go through all of the
dsm-5 diagnostic criteria
i want you to read
this on your own but
also know overall
restlessness overall
fatigue overall muscle
tension irritability
the acronym i gave you
is a really good
acronym of watchers is a
really good way to
screen for generalized
anxiety disorder okay um
now remember if you're
talking to somebody
but if they're high
or they're dependent
on a substance
or they've taken
certain medications
that are known to
have those kind of
side effects, remember
to ask that too.
Remember, you guys
are going to be
doing all sorts of
exams so you're checking
the pupils and
everything anyway.
If it's not explained
by substance
***** or other
medical issues
or other medical
treatments,
then you can start
going down the
pathway of generalized
anxiety disorder.
For treatment,
there are some OMM
treatment strategies
you can talk to
Dr. Abu Spey about.
And then, of course,
there are antidepressants
and cognitive
behavioral therapy.
The combination
of the two, the
cognitive behavioral
therapy and
antidepressants, tend
to work really well.
The reason why
cognitive behavioral
therapy works is
that it really does
target the thoughts.
And I'll talk
about that in a few
slides right now.
And it really talks
about like the fear
stimuli and how to
expose yourself to
whatever it is that
you're afraid of.
Of course, if cognitive
behavioral therapy
is not effective
because the patient
can't still so then
then you're you know you
really need to first
get them to be able
to sit still to be
able to go see a
psychologist and then
you may want to look at
some of these you
know diazepines that
i've listed here but
for the most part
people are able to use
some ssris and snris
and are able to combine
that with cbt now
let's talk about a panic
disorder it's really
the presence of
recurring panic attacks
they're they're acute
they're intense they're
abrupt and they may
have heart palpitations
dizziness nausea and
you want to make sure
that you have them
cleared for any cardiac
ailments before you
call it a panic disorder
and I'll give you an
example of a young man
I'm seeing right now
who has this um so it's
the fear of having a
fearful response right
so a person will avoid
a situation where they
are going to have a
panic attack so if
they're afraid of flying
they will avoid getting
close to an airport
let alone getting on a
plane um if they're
afraid of bridges they're
going to avoid going
on bridges which is
kind of hard to do on
long island but But
there are people who
will not leave the island
because they're afraid
of going on bridges.
So remember,
you want to ask about
what other kinds of
things that they do
to compensate and then
say, well, is that
really good quality of
life? so if somebody
can't fly but their
children live in europe
you know that's a
really tough thing
because otherwise they're
either flying or
they're taking a cruise
which will take them
nearly a month to reach
europe so it does
affect quality of life
again just like journalized
anxiety disorder
the prevalence is
higher for females than
males onset tends to
be adolescence and if
there are other
psychiatric disorders mixed
in with panic disorder
then the outcomes
are really difficult
to to to be positive
so when that happens
by the way then you
really want to find
a qualified clinician
a psychologist
who knows the two
depression and panic
disorder or some or panic
disorder and whatever
other pathology
that they have they
know them really well
so they understand
in the hierarchy
which one to address
first. Now I'm going
to focus on the right
side and that is
the anxiety and the
panic feedback loop.
I'm going to I've
repeated this in another
lecture that you
should be getting so
I really want you guys
to know this which
is that the feedback
loop is say somebody
has a situation when
they're tense and
they're hypermanilating
and there's an
increase in heart
palpitations. So the
example I'm going to
give you is this teenage
young man who was
in college and is
afraid of crowded
spaces and he's afraid
he's going to get sick
in crowded spaces.
Why? Because he went
to a football game
once with his frat
brothers and he got
sick once and he is
afraid that's going
to happen again and
again and again.
So he has a panic
response now.
He is studying
at a Midwestern
college and he
has to get on a
flight to come
back to New York.
But he's tense.
And his thoughts are,
I can't control this.
Something's wrong.
And he actually
called me from the
airport and said,
literally said this,
people can see me.
I look like a freak.
I think something's
going to happen. I'm
going to faint. I don't
think I can do this.
Oh my God, something
bad's going to happen.
I don't think I can
sit here. He couldn't
sit at the airport.
And what happened
was because he couldn't
sit in the airport
and because his
amygdala was blaring he
ended up throwing up
at the airport and he
went back to the hotel
and he had his parents
had to fly in and
he had to find a way
to take several trains
over to come to New
York and what that
incident did was it
created an avoidance
cycle because now he's
learned, I can find a
way to avoid flying.
But you're
still in college
out in Colorado
somewhere.
You're going
to have to find
a way to fly,
right? Otherwise,
it's a three
-day train ride.
But the physiological
response and how it
led to the cognitive
blaring of the amygdala,
which then caused more
anticipatory anxiety
and then led to an
avoidant behavior is
what we break up in in
cognitive behavioral
therapy so the physiological
response gets a
lot of relaxation
training the cognitive
part where the amygdala
is blaring and when
the amygdala is blaring
you're in fight or
flight mode you really
can't eat and this is
what this kid tried
to eat at the airport
because the parents
said why don't you eat
that'll help you calm
down and he threw up
because if you're getting
ready for a battle
of fight or flight you
can't eat right your
body's busy. Your body's
in the sympathetic
nervous system, not
the parasympathetic
nervous system mode.
So he clearly had the
reaction which is
expected of somebody who's
about to get ready to
go into a war zone.
And the avoidance
taught him, I
can find a way
to deal with the
panic by not going
to the airport.
So now I'm working
with him on
progressively getting
closer and closer and
closer to the airport
while dealing with
the physiological
symptoms and also
countering the
negative thoughts about
flying or that the
people can see him.
And we've made videos
and seen online
videos of people at
airports and trying to
show him that people
are too busy looking
at their own phones.
No one cares how
you look. The only
people who are worried
that you're sick are
the people who are
the flight attendants.
They want to make
sure you're not
getting on a plane sick
and make everybody
else sick with you.
Right?
So that's how you treat
somebody with a
panic disorder.
and when you're
talking about
the actual
physiological symptoms
they really do mimic
a cardiac event so
the shortness of breath
they're feeling like
choking they have chest
pains the sweating
the heart palpitations
and I usually ask
them like how bad is
it on a scale of one
to ten how often do
you have it how long
have you had it what
have you're talking
to a patient, and it
doesn't have to be
just for mental health,
it can be for any
symptom, ask onset, ask
about duration, like
how long does it last,
ask about severity,
how bad is it on a
scale of one to ten,
right, ask about
intervals, how
often does it
happen, it happens
every day, several
times a day,
okay, once an hour,
once every three hours,
once a week, once
a month, right?
And the fifth thing
you want to ask
is, what do you do
to deal with it?
But in any kind of
anxiety disorder,
if somebody is
showing up with
symptoms that look
like a cardiac event,
make sure you first
rule that out.
And again, just
like for generalized
anxiety disorder,
cognitive behavioral
therapy and SSRIs tend
to work really well.
And in cognitive
behavioral therapy,
what happens is we
give tools to the
patients that they can
kind of tap into again
and again and apply
them in future
events. They don't
need to be seeing the
psychologist forever
and ever and ever.
And of course, SSRIs
tend to work really well.
And the last disorder
I'm going to talk
about is the social
anxiety disorder. And
these are some people
who may have difficulty
even in a small
group learning class,
how to interact
with people, how
to speak up.
So it has to do
with initiation
of conversations,
and the anxiety
has to do with the
initiation of
conversations. So part
of it clearly is
genetically loaded.
You know, how
is it that they
have genetically
been formed?
Part of it is
observing other people
have difficulty
speaking publicly,
or that when they
tried to, they
may have been
mocked as a child.
So if you think about
somebody who speaks
with a stutter, for
example, our current
president, Biden, has
a stutter. So when he
speaks, he gets stuck
on certain sounds.
And there are treatments
for it. But in
early childhood, children
don't know better.
so they may end up
mocking that one person
who is stuttering
it could be that the
way the way they were
raised in their family
um that they were not
allowed to speak up
much right in certain
cultures children
don't speak children
must be seen not heard
and that used to be
an english saying from
a century ago um or
if you were raised in
a setting where you
didn't have much human
interaction say
you lived up in the
mountains or out in a
farm with like the closest
neighbor was like
half a mile to or a
mile away um and then
of course your brain
physiology is different
and and it's also
that in certain societies
and our cultural
norms expect certain
things from us and some
people may think
that society or that
particular group requires
them not to speak
again like generalized
anxiety disorder and
panic disorder women
tend to suffer from
it more than men
onset is often late
adolescence now if it
is in any way related to
stuttering which is
a speech impediment
you can send your patient
to a speech therapist
who is trained in
stuttering um if any
of you are into watching
movies um king's
speech um the king's
speech actually has
colin firth um deliver
a speech as king
george um queen
elizabeth's father who had
a prominent stutter and
it shows his journey
of treatment and
speech pathology and
speech training to
overcome the stuttering.
So these people may
say, I can't speak.
I feel like I'm
shaking. I think that
people are going to
make fun of me. I feel
like I've got something
stuck in my throat.
I would rather leave
the small group.
And if that is the
patient who's struggling
to tell you about
their symptoms, you
really just want to first
make sure you're not
interrupting them give
them the time give
them the space and
just tell them you're
listening and you're
ready as soon as they
are ready and that
in many ways reduces
their anxiety to be able
to tell you the other
thing is you may also
want them to learn
to like write in notes
and give it to you
not instead of but in
addition to if something
else comes to mind
later on mr smith by
all means please write
and send it to me on
the portal all right um
again you can educate
your patients about
the treatments you can
educate your patients
about the cognitive
behavioral therapy
about ssris snris um and
the tool cbt and
and some kind of
psychopharmacology
tends to work really
well together.
For social anxiety,
the exposure therapy
part is really good
with CBT. So when I'm
working with exposure
therapy, for example,
that young man who
needs to now go back
to Colorado for
college, I'm working
with him on systematically
getting closer
and closer to the
airport and not eating at
the same time and
learning to control his
physiological response
and learning to
control the cognitive
narrative, the dialogue
in his head about
the catastrophe,
the impending doom
he's expecting, and to
reduce that anticipatory
anxiety by saying,
no, there's nothing
dooming about it.
You need to just fly
by MacArthur Airport.
Nothing's going to
happen. You need
to now just fly by
LaGuardia Airport.
Nothing's going
to happen.
Actually, I made him
go sit at JFK last
week. Go sit. You're
doing nothing. Just
sitting. He's just
sitting. and really just
chunking up his time
into manageable portions
where he can manage.
I just have to
go sit. She told me I
just have to go sit.
And in the good
old days, I
would accompany
him to go sit.
Now, HIPAA and all
those things don't
allow me to do that
in public, right?
But that's really
a good go-to
treatment line for
exposure therapy,
for social anxiety
disorder. If you have a
patient who does not want
to take any medications,
this is a really
good um pathway all
right um again cognitive
behavioral therapy
really does affect it
talks about people's
distorted thought
processes or you can think
about like appraisals
like what was your take
on what happened what
did you what was your
own judgment of what
you know how you did
in that in that situation
it could be were
you overthinking were
you catastrophizing was
it all or none um was
it everything i see
is through the lens
of like gray and black
everything is dark and
to catch those patterns
and then to start
changing them all right
so that's this is
exactly what i just
described to you you
catch a situation
what are your thoughts
um what are the
emotions associated
with those thoughts
and then did you
behave in a way that
reinforced your emotions
and your thought
like if you think i'm
being if the thought
is i'm not good enough
and i'm worthless and
the core belief system
is i'm worthless
and i'm unloved you
will act you will behave
in a way that makes
you stay in the place
of not being worthy so
you will avoid contact
with others you will
avoid eye contact
you will avoid social
interactions and
therefore and you and
that requires a lot of
hard work so you will
be physically tired um
but it reinforces
the idea of I'm not
good enough see I
wasn't able to make
eye contact I couldn't
do it and so in
cognitive behavioral
therapy I chop up
different parts of
this feedback loop
I want you to be aware
that you know the DSM
-5 definitely updated
a lot of psychiatric
disorders so remember
to go look at them um
also go look at you
know how ocd and ptsd
may overlap the ones
that i talked about ocd
and ptsds tend to be
in an extreme end of
all anxiety disorders
i know you guys got
your own lecture for
that um so just remember
to keep them separated
and remember you can
always go back and look
at the om techniques
here and i want you
to just look at these
for your references.
All right, good luck.